[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
raconte-moi camping pidgin a dit le
grand yaka était le plus grand prix
charles de monde
ne voit on n'a pas l'impression quand
y'a qu'à vous valez couler l'eau prendra
vente dernier bateau tu sais tu n'as pas
le droit je suis de gagner cas et je
dois gazier là forcément vous jouez mal
en vous perdez voilà aussi pourquoi il
veut apporter du goûter enfin fait
bienvenu
il y avait quoi fonds ne prêterait et
bicici coltene de te faire plaisir titus
lé sir toi mon petit lit au maire fait
grand yaka
mais vous vous rendez déplacer mes
bâtons mois le gremio cas tu m'accuses
et titus plus grand encore wendel
presser pendant que babel dans ton nez
tu m'insultes et titus tu veux me
demande de partir vous demande pendant
va mais est bordé votre coin tenant oui
aussi je te rappelles tu auras diby le
coup de batteur chance
voilà un paravent voudrais me casser
dernière est le grand riad à part avant
me voile et michel ce volet le parapente
2004 ces dernières et quand tu sais pas
ce que je les trappeurs et par là que
parce que je suis le gars comme moi je
suis le plus beau voilà alors j'ai le
droit de tricher novembre
seulement voilà si tu espèce de l'autre
côté je ne le verrai pas mais il vaut
mieux que je me mettais de 20
[Musique]
voilà comment cela dit si je le verrais
pas ces avis c'est passé de l'autre côté
jeu je ne le saurai pas comme un faire
un mail qui embête qui tu arrives bien
tu vas faire le guet le droit date jeu
suite naturelle pour le peuple de suite
jaune tient alors tu mets tes maîtres de
nos deux côtés du parana et tu me
préviendra lorsque tu n'iras pas si
titus et au bon vous voulez que je donne
ce n'est pas dans mon contrat
au fond je regrette c'est follement
excitant ça et si tu vois pas si titus
appel à moi il n'aura dimino coup de
bâton on chantera bien trop prudent
halte repas
je pleurais être
notre mal quand il faut que vous
m'aidiez à me donner de la voix si chaud
que nous allons chers écoute plein gros
plan et la mercantine et ouaté jour
pâtissent
obama signale un grand yaka way s'est
fatigué de rester debout way a plus à
vous prendre l'apparence avoue reposera
attend tous repeints d'accord tu couches
de ton copain elle boit du bien
[Musique]
kanye west ou juillet mais tient
absolument à rien et pourtant vous savez
je dois être la poubelle jure je suis
d'épisodes de fatiguer moins ferme à
nation et compta jusqu'à 100 ça me fera
du bien au énième toi et 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23
24 mai
voilà ce que nous avons perdu tant de
gauriac a très bien fait et à plaide
auprès d'une autre étoile